Film Courage: What are two or three things
that a director cannot afford to get wrong
because if they do, the movie is ruined?
Mark W. Travis: Wow!
That’s a big question.
Two or three things they can’t get wrong…
Film Courage: Right…cannot afford.
Mark W. Travis: Okay.
There is one thing Karen I think is really
important that I’ll include myself in this
that we all fall into.
A trap that we all fall into.
And what I call it is the trap of assumption,
okay.
The trap of assumption is let’s say I have
a script and I really like it.
I’m moved by it, okay?
My assumption would be that other people will
it and be moved by it.
Somebody else could read it, or see this film
or whatever and could be moved by it.
I could be wrong.
I’ll even take a scene between a husband
and wife and there is an argument going on
and the husband is really angry at the wife
for some reason and to me he’s angry at
her because of her attitude.
Her impatience.
I’ve done something very small.
And my assumption is that anybody watching
it would get that.
It may not be true.
The problem is this: when we’re looking
at a script, in a script, I’m just going
to take one scene, I can read that scene Karen.
And I can read it.
Let’s say it’s just two pages, I can read
that scene and say “I got it.
I can see what’s happening.
I can feel the energy between the two characters.
I can feel the conflict.
I can feel the resolution.
I can feel all the obstacles.
Everything that they’re going through.
I get it.
Now quite honestly those two pages, none of
what I felt is there.
I can tell you that right now.
None of it.
None of the conflict and even the characters
is there.
All it is, is words typed on a page.
No different than a novel, it’s just words
typed on a page.
What happens which we all have to recognize
is when you look at a script you project into
that material what you believe is happening.
Anybody who reads a script can suddenly hear
the characters, they can see the characters.
Where is that coming from?
It’s not coming from the page.
It’s not there.
There’s no pictures of the characters there.
There’s no action there.
Nothing.
There is no emotion there.
No performance there.
Nothing.
So what we do, what every human being does
is we project into those pages what we believe
is happening.
In other words, those pages are triggering
me.
Those pages that I am reading trigger Mark.
Mark’s history.
Mark’s life experience, Mark’s expectation.
Everything.
It’s coming from me.
So I project into it.
Now Karen, you’ll do the same thing.
But why should I assume that your projection
is the same as mine?
That’s the danger of assumption.
I’ll assume that you’ll get it the same
way I do.
Not true.
Maybe close?
I don’t know.
So the trap is the trap of assumption.
I assume that you’re going to respond that
way.
I could see a scene and go “That’s so
moving!” and you’re going “What?
I don’t get it.”
My reaction was, it was moving.
Your reaction was that it wasn’t moving.
The assumption was you should get it.
Thinking that just because it works for me,
it should work for everybody else.
Yes, ironically, the flip side of that is
also true.
I as a director have to make the movie for
me.
I can’t make it for anybody else.
So I have to allow a certain level of assumptions
are going on.
I’m assuming because I’ve made a movie
that I really like that it is moving to me,
I have to assume it is going to be moving
to enough people that lots of people are going
to like it.
So we’re trapped in the world of assumption.
But trapped in that we have to do it but be
aware aware that it could be a problem.
Film Courage: Okay.
So how is someone aware of their own assumptions?
Let’s suppose you think that these two pages
of very moving dialogue between two characters
is just heart-wrenching because you see the
world that way or that scene, but how are
you bouncing that off someone else…I don’t
know if I’m making myself clear?
Mark W. Travis: Yeah.
I think so and I think I have an answer for
it.
Let’s stay with this one scene because sometimes
just looking at one scene because a movie,
you don’t just make a whole movie, as you
know.
You make all these little scenes put them
together and it becomes a movie.
So you have to be very focused, very myopic
about that scene.
So let’s say a scene between a husband and
wife.
And getting back to you, how do I deal with
my assumptions.
One of the biggest assumptions I as a director
can have, any director, every director will
have…I read the scene, I know how it should
play.
I, as the director know how this scene should
Should…now I am the director so I get to
decide.
I get to decide how I want the actress to
play the mother and how I want the actor to
play the father.
Now this is what a lot of directors will do
and I can tell you right now because working
with a lot of directors, I will say to a director
who says this is how it should go and I’ll
say “How do you know?”
“Well, that’s clearly the way it should
play” and I’ll talk to them about projection.
So there is that assumption.
Now we’re going to mix with that something
else which makes it even more difficult.
You have the two actors.
Now those two actors read the script and they’re
making assumptions.
The actress will say “Oh, I know how to
play this.”
The actor will say “Oh, I know how to play
it.”
Now we have three people who have different
points of view on how it should play and I
can tell you right now the director, me and
those two actors, right?
We’re all wrong.
We’re right about our assumptions.
We are right about our opinion.
But we are wrong.
Our opinion actually does not matter.
All three of us.
The only opinion that matters is the opinion
of the characters.
The characters, the husband and wife, they
know.
And we’re trying to tell them how they should
behave.
The actors are trying to tell them how to
behave by controlling them.
I’m trying to tell the actors how to control
the characters, how to portray the characters.
If I can get to the character, get to the
truth of the character my assumption may be
blown right out of the water and the actress
may be, too.
Or not.
I don’t know.
But my job as the director is to serve the
characters.
That’s getting back to what your question
was before, serve the story.
Not my version of the story, their version
of the story.
I want to get to the truth of who they are.
I want to get to the truth of the characters
that the writer created that the writer is
also making assumptions about.
The writer may even tell me “Oh, it should
go this way.”
And I say “Well I don’t know if you know
either?”
Let’s get to the character and this gets
down to the interrogation process which is
talking to the character.
I want to know from the character what they
want, what they think, what they feel.
The one thing is very important which may
have been in the DVD [Hollywood Film Directing:
The Masterclass by Mark W. Travis] I gave
you, probably is.
One thing that is very important, this is
a concept to me that is so clear and obvious
but nobody talks about it because as soon
as I bring it up, people go “Oh, yeah!”
The characters in your movie.
The characters in this scene.
These two people, husband and wife, whoever
they might be, are not in a movie.
They’re not.
They are two people who are in their life.
They are in a moment in their life which happens
to be the scene trying to achieve whatever
they’re trying to achieve that is just two
people.
They are not in a movie.
They do not have a script.
And we are trying to present them as authentically
as we can to a viewer.
Well in order to do that we need to present
them as authentically as we can to a viewer.
Well in order to do that, we need to honor
them, not my point of view necessarily.
Not the actors point of view necessarily but
them.
Let’s present them as authentically as we
can.
I have learned so much about characters and
story by talking to the characters in a way
(and I mean this seriously) dismissing a little
bit of what the writer says, what the actors
say, and even what I think.
I go and I talk to the characters and I am
sometimes so educated and enlightened about
who those people are.
They are the ones I am here to serve.
They are the ones that the writer is here
to serve.
And we’re all there in service of characters.
So let’s talk to them of the interrogation
process (which we can talk about later) as
a way to get to them and get us, the writer,
the directors and the actors out of the way.
Many times getting to the truth of the story,
the actors, the writers and the director are
the biggest obstacle.
We are in the way of what we’re trying to
achieve.
Question for the Viewers: What are your thoughts
on the “trap of assumption?"